- On this episode I'm in a good mood
because the Jets crushed the Dolphins
and we go on an epic rant
at the end of the show
around the inflection point.
♫ Hey
(hip hop dance music)
♫ Gary Vee
♫ You ask questions
♫ and I answer them
♫ This is
♫ The #AskGaryVee Show ♫
(synthesizer bass)
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 167
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
I'm in a very good mood.
The Jets won, that is good.
- [Staphon] I'm in a bad mood.
- You're in a bad mood?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- 'Cause Kobe's retiring.
That's such a, that's like a humblebrag.
Oh, I'm really sad
'cause
- [Staphon] I am though.
- a guy that won me
five world championships
is finally 40 years old and retiring.
- [Staphon] I grew up with him.
- I understand you grew up with him
But you know sports, it
should be pretty simple,
did you win, did you lose?
You won with Kobe.
I know it's sad and
emotional but you'll be fine.
India you did a surprise trip to,
after you said here
- [India] I did.
- on the show that you
were not going anywhere
you went to San Francisco.
- I did go--
- That was good, you
had a good Thanksgiving,
DRock, everybody?
Pierce the VanyerMedia
employee joining us.
- Hello.
- [Gary] Good Thanksgiving?
- It was great!
- Why don't you tell the
Vayner Nation a little bit
about what you do here
and things of that nature.
- Sure, I'm Pierce White,
@piercewhite on Instagram.
I am on our
- communications team and so--
- [Gary] Right hook, like it?
- Yeah, lovin' it.
- Goin' well?
- It's amazing.
- Very good, how long
have you been at Vayner?
- Almost a year and a half,
- Straight outta college
- [Gary] Nice.
- so love it here.
- Straight outta college (laughs).
Yeah so, I'm in a good
mood, no salty Monday.
And now we have an entire
week, I'm here this week,
so we'll have a lotta shows.
The buildup will be extreme
for the battle for New York.
The Jets versus the
Giants, both teams' seasons
on the lines, a little
bit less for the Giants
because their division
is so bad but it's going
to be a huge game, it
is going to be ruckus.
I'm going to actually
make a real commitment
to a substantial Snapchat
story of my experience
this weekend going to
that Jets, Giants game.
I as a Jets fan, clearly
the team that's won less
in New York.
Giants have won four
Super Bowls in my mouth.
I've been to none during my fandom.
We are clearly the little brother in town.
We do have that chip on our shoulder,
this is a very big game for me.
I'm quite emotional about it.
I'm excited and I jumped off the bandwagon
of making predictions.
The Jets played much better
than I expected yesterday.
I'm probably not gonna make a prediction
because now I'm gonna go with
the suit you know worked.
So we'll go with that route
but I will talk quite about,
a big about it and all you Giant fans.
This'll be good, let's do some,
are we taping the show on Friday?
I think we are right?
All you Giant fans please go on Instagram.
Make your 15 second
trash talk videos to me
for this game, let's
really get the juices going
for this game because
I am fired up for it.
I'm fired up for it.
In 1988 we knocked the
Giants out of the playoffs
in the last game of the
year, that was awesome.
In 1993, when I was a
senior in high school,
we beat the Giants, since then
it's not been going as well.
And so I'd like to get
back in the win column.
India, with that I would
like to get into the show.
- [India] From Matthew.
- Matthew, oh before I get into the show,
I would also like to say
that I hope everybody
had a wonderful Thanksgiving.
It's a great time, I feel
like Thanksgiving is one
of the real great vacations of all time.
You know it kind of
really starts on Tuesday.
People kinda travel on Wednesday.
For me there's nothing like that Wednesday
when I know everybody's checked out
and it's really like Wednesday
night, Thursday night,
Friday night, Saturday night.
All quite relaxing and
I really enjoyed it,
had an amazing time with my family
and so I hope you did it as well.
Now I am ready to get into the show.
- [Voiceover] Matt says
"The golf coaching world
"has been boring for way too long!
"What would #AskGaryVee
do to create a bad a-
"golf coaching business?"
- Well golf is boring.
I'm just kidding with that.
So wait, Matthew starts
with golf coaching,
- [India] The golf coaching world's
been boring for way too long.
- [Gary] Got it.
Now look I mean, every world
is boring in a lot of ways
outside of heavy entertainment
genres or high energy genres
until a personality comes along.
I would say for the
common American financing
and finance news was boring
until Jim Cramer came along.
I take a lot of pride in the fact
that a lotta people through the years,
tens of thousands maybe
hundreds of thousands,
have told me that wine was
boring until I came along
and so you're always one personality away.
You know Howard Cosell
changed sportscasting.
I think you're one extreme,
high-energy, entertaining person away
from changing an entire culture.
And so this is quite basic.
I mean to me any time
something becomes exciting
it's on the back of a human
being making it exciting.
And so, Emeril Lagasse
made chef culture, you know, less boring
by saying pow or whatever he did right and
that was in the early 90's.
So the answer to your questions is,
and I assume you're
alluding this way Matthew,
listen Matthew if you've got the chops,
if you've got the charisma,
if you're entertaining enough
then you will be that person.
And I think that's an important thing
for everybody to understand.
Everything is based and
predicated on the actions,
you know everybody who wants
a change, you know my tagline
on Wine Library TV is we're
changing the wine world
whether they like it or not.
Caught a lot of people's
attention and brings a lot
of people coming to me
around this question.
If you, you're actions
have to represent the thing
that you want to happen and
so please anybody who's trying
to change the hair extension
world, or the art world,
or the music world, or you
know whatever, the making apps
for the iPhone, like
whatever thing you're trying
to change you're either
changing it or you're not.
Your actions are creating
your change and so when I hear
that question, if you're
not putting out the content
that's compelling and
entertaining experience well then
there's no talking about it.
Like if you've been doing
it, then it's happening and
if you're not doing it, it's
not happening and saying
that you're gonna do it or asking me to,
for the answer to it,
it's just the actions.
It's every single boring
world can be changed.
Science, there's people that
make science interesting
and literature interesting,
it's out there.
Like LeVar Burton made reading
interesting with his rainbow.
I mean like you know anybody can do it.
So, that's the answer.
It's just a human being coming
along and being entertaining
within the genre and having the expertise
to not have the experts
laugh them off the stage
and make it seem like they're
a comedian, just doing that.
And I think that's what it comes down to.
The equal parts, you actually know
what the hell you're talking
about with golf lessons
and golf culture and really know golf
and can really teach and then you're also
ridiculously handsome and
charismatic to execute
that entertainment factor.
- [India] Um, Anastasia.
- ♫ Anastasia ♫
- [Voiceover] Anastasia asks, "In the age
"of screenshot reposts on social--"
- I like screenshots.
- [India] Yeah (laughing)
- [Gary] (laughing) I
got you with that one.
- [India] I was like yes.
- I just like 'em.
- [India] Say something else.
- I just like for you to
know that I like them.
- [India] Now we know.
- Okay.
- [Voiceover] "How do you see
brands protecting themselves?
"Do we say goodbye to copyrights?"
- Listen copyright is on,
on, is, is on watch right?
Like copyright's been put on shade like
it needs to understand
it is being trolled.
Yeah, and on the fip side there's
a lotta push the other way
but yes, we're not you know, we're not
in the same world as
we used to be anymore.
Technology has created a scenario where,
we all collectively
have to figure this out.
I mean music was put
on blast by Napster and
then we had a whole decade
or two of innovation.
Apple came along, figured out
how to make it compelling.
YouTube came along found out
how to make it compelling
over time, at first it
was not as compelling
to the copyright people.
Yeah, I think, listen we
will never fully get away
from where somebody creates something
that they're not being compensated.
I don't think, we're too far
down the culture of that.
On the flip side it's a rub
because the truth is a
lotta people want people
to use their stuff.
They want both, they want both right?
They want to use, you want
them to use your music
or picture in the commercial
so you get commercial success
but you wanna be compensated for that.
The truth is there's so much
content and so many things
that can be used that alternatives
of things that are free
are becoming more and more of the fad.
I think that much like we
answered the Adele question,
which worked out for her.
I think, you know, I think we use shmadele
and I think this was three
or four episodes ago.
I think every person whose
watching and listening needs
to make a decision for
themselves if they're better off
letting people use their stuff or not.
I watch people use my
imagery all the time.
Somebody made a salty
V t-shirt on TeePublic,
the team hit me up,
they're like whadda we do.
Do we wantta take it down?
I decided no, that's in my
benefit, that if people buy that
I won't make the 18
cents or four dollars or
whatever it is per shirt that's
okay 'cause it's valuable
for me at this moment.
On the flip side people use
my image to sell like bullshit
like information products
where I don't believe in it,
that's bad.
I do tell them to take that down.
That's a copyright issue
'cause that's falsely
making it look like I'm endorsing
some bullshit $300 ebook or course.
So I think you have to make
an individual investment.
Weigh the value props,
you know there was a vine
for, I brought this up
before, where the girl used
a booty shaking song in her twerking video
that made that song shoot up.
It was like 10 years old,
shoot up to number 10
in the iTunes Store.
If they would've taken that
down, they would've missed out
on all the sales of the album
which they made money on.
So you've gotta be
strategic in this new world.
It's not a one size
fits all kind of answer.
What're you looking at India?
- [India] I don't know,
I was just thinking
about what you're saying.
- Okay.
- [India] I probably
wasn't really looking at--
- Well I can tell there's
nothing super interesting
going on back there.
- [India] Well, yeah exactly.
(people laughing)
- I agree.
- [India] People.
- Just peeps.
- [India] Um, from Matt.
- Matty.
- [Voiceover] Matt says
"Richard Branson says clients
"do not come first.
"Employees come first.
"Do you agree or disagree and why?"
- I agree and Matt, Matt?
Matt, I agree and I've been
pounding that for 166 episodes,
so at least 40 times, so
I feel very comfortable
in kind of dodging this
answer 'cause I think one
of the things, the repetitiveness
of the show is something
I challenge myself with always recognizing
there's so many new people watching and
there's a lot of people watching
so I'll just go very fast.
This doesn't get my juices
going and I'm not trying
to diss Matt, I assume you're
fairly new so I'm excited,
it's not even close.
To me it is fundamentally my
employees then my customers
then my own interests and
that has been the backbone
of my success.
I feel like you end up
with a whole lot if you go
in that order and I think
my actions have spoken
to that at this company.
I've got a lotta people that have worked
in the agency industry for a long time and
have been surprised by how
hard I push back on clients.
We've fired a client historically,
which is sacrilege even
though people say it and
so yes I think Richard's correct.
And I think anybody
successful like a Branson,
that's built an actual organization.
Not as a single entertainer,
or as an investor,
or somebody built a product.
Somebody that actually built a
600, a 6,000, a 60,000 person
organization or a six person organization,
successfully recognizes how
much value in the people
there really is.
I also happen to like people
which makes it even easier
for me so just keeping
it very basic I say yes.
I'm curious to your strategy
of picking that question India.
- Well, I know it's been
awhile since we've talked
about that POV you have and we're getting
so many new viewers and
I checked the last time
we really talked about that was
like in the 40's episode so.
- Fine, come with real
data and answers India.
No, really good job, yeah so
now that India's guilted me
into going a little bit deeper here.
- [India] No I wasn't--
- No, No listen I mean
well I appreciate it, I'll
go a little bit even further.
To me it's a very big deal and, and,
and it's so surprising to
me law firms, consultants,
agencies, where they
actually sell people's hours.
That they're not completely
infatuated with that process.
I get it for Wine Library,
where like we were selling wine.
The end result was a
transaction with wine.
The end result here is a transaction
with another human being
against their hours.
So again if you were in a
business where that is the case,
you run multiple gyms
and you have trainers,
you again law firm, consultants.
Anybody who's listening
to this who has a business
that people's hours are being
sold should be religious,
I mean cultish about caring
about their people and
then anybody that's selling a byproduct
of it your results are gonna,
the shelves are gonna be
stocked better at Wine Library.
You're gonna get a better
answer out of recommendation
from Wine Library if you
care about your people,
even though the end result
product is a bottle of wine or
if you go into a bicycle
shop the end result is still
selling a bike but if
Ricky is happy when he came
into the shop and you come in
for a bike, he's gonna spend
that extra 15 minutes
enthusiastically tryin' to tell you
that this tire is better than
that tire, that shit matters.
- [Voiceover] Jacob asks
"Would Gary take 20 minutes out
"of his day to watch #AskGaryVee?"
- No, I would not watch the show.
I know I've lost viewers
because of this answer.
I've watched that, it happen.
I've actually been curious
'cause there's been like 10
or 11 people emphatically
saying I'm not watching anymore
'cause you, I get it.
And then I kinda like
follow, like I tag them
and I kinda like follow-up
and I'm like oh crap,
I really lost them.
Which makes me happy and sad.
Misha used to do that, my
daughter used to do that.
She's like I'm happy and sad and so
that's where that came from.
And so, the answer is I wouldn't
because it's not how I roll.
But I also would've never
watched one episode.
So I think that's an important thing
for the people listening and watching.
The way I learn is different.
The way I do things is different.
And there's no right or
wrong, as a matter of fact
my biggest issue is that I
wish I had a little bit more
of that in me.
I wish that I would read a
book or two here and there
or I wish I consumed people's content
that I was aligned with
or could learn from.
It's just, I'm just too
into the anthropology
of just watching.
I'm sitting at the
Knick's game last night,
tough double, tough overtime
loss to the Rockets,
Michael Lang if you're watching screw you.
(Gary makes squeaking noise)
I spent all my time watching
everybody on their phones.
And by the way it was an Instagram,
Snapchat only world from 16 to 46.
New York crowd but super
fascinating so that's how I learn.
I learn by watching, I
learn by watching all
of your behaviors in the
comments and then seeing
what you do.
I learn by all of you being so honest
about telling me your truth, learned a lot
about a lot of you individually.
Helps me interact with you so
I'm on that side of the coin.
So the answer is no, I
would not watch the show.
- [India] The next one's from Malik.
- Malik.
- [India] What advice do
you have for someone--
- Not Malik Sealy, none of
you know who Malik Sealy is.
- [Voicover] Sounds familiar.
- Old school basketball player.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
Played for your favorite teams.
- [Voiceover] I know.
- [India] (talking quietly)
- Think about the Syracuse or St. John's
definitely a local
school, I think St. John.
- [India] We could pretend
it's Malik Sealy if you want.
- I'm gonna pretend that it's Malik Sealy.
Wow, Malik thanks for
watching the show man.
I was a big fan of your college career.
- [Voiceover] Malik asks
"What advice do you have
"for someone who finds out
that they're not cut out
"to be an entrepreneur?"
- Oh yeah, I get it
Malik 'cause you played,
I'm just kidding.
Being an entrepreneur
is not some great thing.
It's just as good as being anything.
It's just as good as being
a great, I mean listen
as much as it's amazing for
me that I inspire people
to maybe build businesses
that then is a gateway drug
to happiness in their
life, I'd be, I'd feel
really compelled to be financially secure,
have better work, life
balance and be a brain surgeon
and save people's lives on a daily basis.
Like there's a lot of things,
or like some of the things,
do you know, you know maybe
not as financially rewarding
but if you're wired to be
a great guidance counselor.
Impacting teenagers through
those really difficult,
and being a guidance
counselor in a high school
for real and if you're not
mailing it in and full of shit
and only wanna be there nine
to three and you're out,
if you really are in it.
It just comes down,
you know it's funny, so
that would be cool to
be a guidance counselor
which leads me to the point
that made me think of this
which is if you're really passionate.
And I don't use that
word as you guys know.
I kinda stay away from that
'cause I think it's kind of
a bullshitty word, but if you're
truly passionate and really
into what you do and you
really give it your all.
Like if you really do, whether
you do it for yourself or
within an organization
that you believe in or
that you think will get you
to the place you want to be one day.
Which is really what I try to build here.
Which is one of those two things right?
It's a place you want to be,
around me and that energy
and that success and that
machine for the rest of your life
or you feel like the
things you learn at Vayner
over a two, six, 12, 19
year career lends itself
to the things you want
to do in the future.
If you're lucky enough to be
in one of those scenarios,
regardless of what you do,
if you passionately get up in the morning.
If you got up this morning
at six a.m. like I did
and were fired up to go, of
course 'cause the Jets won,
but fired up to go and your
to go was you're gonna go
in the office and from nine to
four you're gonna clean teeth
and work on cavities 'cause
you're a badass, motherf-
dentist that loves the teeth
game well then you've won.
My advice is if you figured out
you weren't an entrepreneur,
well then you're just like
one of those contestants
on American Idol.
That went there, you gave
an at-bat, good for you, kudos.
You stood in front of Simon
and he said you f- stink
and you're like crap and then
you went home and it aired
a couple months later and
everybody laughed at you
and on Twitter they said you
stunk and you're like alright
maybe I'm you know weird
and maybe I can't sing.
Now what you need to do
is comma, move on and try
to figure out what you can
do, what you are good at
and more importantly what do you love?
And then there's the other big
semicolon, I don't even know
that's definitely not the
proper grammar, but like
there's the other parallel thing.
Which is you don't give a
crap that you suck at singing.
You can't breathe and believe
that you can do anything else.
You're just gonna sing.
Awesome, go get a job at a karaoke bar.
Go, work at a music store
and just sit there all day
and sing.
There's absolutely this remarkable balance
of what makes you happy, what
makes you the most money.
Some people are just blessed,
lucky or grind their way
into it or were born with
the talent of like being able
to do both.
I would tell you that if
I could make enough money
to make me happy because I
want it, because I like it.
I like the game, it's the
game of it more so than it
but go, I've often thought
about fully retiring
and just garage saleing.
You know?
But the problem is I just have
too much other ambition and
other things I want to do and
it's really not predicated
on the money but like the
garage, I'm very close,
I'm one DNA strand away from being a guy
that makes $87,000 a year
garage saleing every day.
And that's cool and I have
so many friends and relatives
that are rip crap happy that
tried to be entrepreneurs,
failed just like I would fail
to be a professional
hockey player or a singer,
and have gone on to
massively happy, it's just
about being happy and so my
advice for an entrepreneur
would be dust it off, be
like alright that's not me,
even though it's a hot
thing to be right now,
and let me go figure out
what I can do that is.
To me the magic is what's the
thing that you can do the best
that you like the most?
What's that cross section?
And then that's a great place to be right?
It may not be perfect,
you might not be like Kobe
who loves playing, you
can see it in his face,
loves playing basketball more
than breathing and happened
to be phenomenal at it which
is why you become Kobe.
There's a reason there's Kobe.
There's a reason there's Madonna.
There's a reason that there
are these one-named people.
Cher, you know, there's a reason,
let's cut to the chase.
Because they happen to have
at the inflection point,
the passion and love and
desire and the talent
for that thing and found that thing.
Which is a whole nother category of things
to be successful.
I feel like I've had
that but I also recognize
in so many not that exact thing
or the upper-middle class version of it.
The eight on a 10 point scale, the 7.2,
the 9.1, the 5.4.
That's what you're lookin' for you know,
that's what you're lookin' for.
And then there's the balance
of risk and practicality.
So many people are not
born with the risk gene
of an entrepreneur.
You're just not willin'
to take the chance,
it's just too scary.
I just don't know the other way.
It was too scary not to get F's for me.
I've always fought the system.
I can't conform to what
people think is right.
It's just not how I see the
world, it's just not what I see.
So, I think tripling down on you.
If you found out you're not entrepreneur,
you probably weren't
self-aware to begin with
to realize that you weren't
gonna win in that anyway.
You're probably just following
a narrative of what's sexy
or what's attractive and you need
to take a big boy, big girl
step back in your life and say
okay let's get really real with ourselves.
What is the thing I'm best
at that I like the most
and then triple down on that.
Put yourself in that position.
Quit your job or quit the failed startup
and go start whittling
wood 'cause you might just
be great at it and you can
sell the goddamn little statues
in an amazing museum shop in Wyoming.
Be happy as goddamn hell.
Make a good buck.
You're one Instagram photo
away from somebody saying
look how amazing this is.
Now you're the wood
whittlinger for the celebrities
and like this is real,
you know but this is real.
This is how shit goes down and it's funny
and I know it's a funny thing.
I'm glad I got you India but
what do you think happened
with DJ's?
They just loved it so much
and so they made 500 bucks
on the side at parties.
DJ AM, I watch Doc U, and
then he became the one
that did it for Madonna's parties and
then he got paid a million
dollars to be the DJ in residence
in Vegas.
Funny things happen when you
triple down on your strengths.
A lotta times the world comes to you.
It may not seem like you
can make, too many people
are like I'm awesome
at this and I love this
but it doesn't make a lotta money.
I hate that because that is
the place to go 'cause all
of a sudden the world comes to you.
1979 I'm a great chef and I
love cooking more than life
but I'm not gonna be a chef
because it only pays $50,000
at this restaurant and I'm the help.
Yeah until that 22 year old
then in 1995 is 37
and celebrity chefs are now a thing
and she has her own show.
I mean like, that's what I think.
Cool, that was fun,
that was fun to be in
that bubble for a second.
- [India] We have a podcast to get in.
- Oh we still have a podcast question.
Okay thank you for everybody
who's been watching
and I will close the show right now and
then we'll do a podcast thing.
Question of the day.
You know what, what is
that inflection point
for you right now?
We've been very truthful,
I like it, let's go there.
Right now tell me your inflection point.
The thing you like the most
that you're the best at.
I just wanna know what that thing is and
then as a little context play for me comma
are you actually doing
that or are you right now
being practical, paying back
loans, you make $200,000
being a lawyer so you
can't do that thing because
that would only make 50K.
What is your inflection point?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop dance music)